я Вітя я дуже люблю Коли все працює як
треба тому останні вісім років Я працюю
слюсарем автомеханіком
Чесно кажучи я Скільки себе пам'ятаю я
завжди любив все лагодити і ви знаєте
оці типові історії коли хобі може стати
твоєю професією в моєму випадку це
правда тому я одразу пішов вчитися на
слюсаря автомеханіка в місцеве училище
десь мені було 14-15 років Я купив свій
перший мопед а потім я познайомився з
своїм найкращим другом Сашком він мені
багато чого розказав показав жінка ж
працював на сто я до нього приходив із
одного питаннями Сашко Це що машину
поняв тепер такими питаннями мене
задовбуємо як команда
Ну ми ж тут не просто в моторах
колупаємось Ну хоча цей теж любимо але
від нашої роботи залежить безпека людей
справність транспорту зараз важливий як
ніколи клієнтів в мене побільшало тому я
залишаюсь тут і роблю свою роботу люди
повинні мати можливість заїхати на
ремонт чи на то за потреби такі речі
показують що життя не зупиняється це
дуже цінують все працює завдяки нам
[музика]